uh the next talk if chung if you can
stop sharing your screen and bully can
take over
yes
okay bo uh you're still muted
can you hear me yes good
and also see the screen
uh great i assume everyone see my screen
okay actually today uh today's talk is
all about the uh uncertainty estimation
in your policy setting so
it's also including my talk uh this i'm
bo
and i'm from uh google marine and also
this work is
joint work with a fair england nikon
chavantel
i don't need to talk about the
importance of the uncertainty as
mentioned in your foreign setting so
i will give a very brief introduction
about the notation i use
and then i directly go to the brief
recall about
a linear programming form of policy
value and then
i will go to the major part of the test
talk which is
what we call that corners and later this
conclusion
uh okay here's the preliminary setting
and basically i think everyone here
knows the mdp and i don't need to go
through line by line
i just want to give a notation
connection here what i used
uh later i use s as that instead of
states
it has a set of actions and t
here stands for the transition
probability r stands for the minor word
gamma is a discount factor and mu0s
assume its initial state distribution
and uh the policy actually the
conditional distribution if i give you a
state it will produce a distribution
over the action space
and we defy the value of policy by
expectation over
uh trajectory return which is defined as
you accumulate the reward along your
infinite hormone return but with some
discounting factors the expectation here
takes over
all randomness including the
transitional criteria the reward
the reward and also your uh policy
so i think this is uh
pretty much about the what i will use in
this talk
uh and also i will formally define what
is uh opposite policy evaluation here
basically is uh there's no chance you
can visit
the environment but only a data set
from the historic interaction with
other behavioral policy and this data is
looks like a tuple which is saying
you have english s 0 a 0 from
initial distribution and also a0 is
conditioned
as 0 and generated by your policy and
as a reward as prime here is
uh from distribution where
it's played by other uh policies so
basically you don't know it you just get
some other
uh agent historic experience
and a prime here came from the target
distribution
and our goal is trying to estimate the
uh positive value which is defined in my
previous slide
without knowing the transition operator
and also rewards
and we also assume we don't know uh who
collected data so basically
that means you don't you cannot access
to the policy
which uh collect data for you so we call
this task as part uh behavior agnostic
or possible evaluation
uh okay until now i think that's pretty
much the briefing clutch of the print
premium and next i will also recall what
a few introduced on monday
and i'm not sure i think not everyone
listened to
uh talks so i will give a very very
brief introduction
about this programming formulation for
the policy value
uh here the upper three line
is the primal form of the uh
linear programming for policy value and
the bottom three
row is the dual formation of this linear
programming
uh basically we can introduce let's look
at the primal form that is saying
uh the q function you want to push
through corners such that it's equal to
the
q function is in the physical step such
that the queue is bigger or equal to a
future backup and plus your current
immediate reward
but because the object function is
pushing towards the minimum so it will
push this q into the
corner case so basically eventually the
solution of this linear programming will
satisfy this function only in q
equals to the r plus the next step
i mean future backup and but first of
all the dual formation actually is
saying
uh talking about the stationary
visitation distribution saying
the station limitation will be equal to
your
uh backup your
historic experience but with one minus
gamma it came from
zero and pi uh
and i think this is the primal deal
formation for the
policy value and here is
because it's so complicated there's you
see
we can't change through satisfied to
every state and action here
so basically we need to we don't have
any
existing as far as i know there's no
existing
server can solve this problem even i
give you the policy
and if i give you the model so
one way to formulate it is we use the
lag logic
such that it can rewrite to expectation
where the sample came from mu zero
pi under the d of
dd uh so this is very standard technique
by
uh you just apply like logic to the
problem either primal theory will get
end up like this like launching and
uh based on this formulation actually
there's
there's many many algorithm from code
recently
uh we summarize it as a dice family
uh from last year to this year at the
beginning
i don't think this formation is realized
and
recently we uh we unified all this
formation
into uh this lagrangian formation and
this paper is published this europe's
system europe
uh the reason we call it dice is because
we are estimating the station
distribution correction stands for
d s a over your behavior
your data collected
and then with this formation after you
solve this lagrangian you get
the point matter of the targeted policy
so until now i think i gave a very very
brief introduction about
what happened in past a year about to
the poll
uh point at semester point as a matter
of the policy
of policy evaluation and
now beyond what scotland
challenge and today about to the
importance application of uncertainty
actually
back to the history there are already
many many people talking about
uncertainty uh in two phase
in two phases first one is the
optimistic
view of the uh how can handle the
uncertainty
actually that's it's the basic principle
in the
reinforced learning saying when you
handle the uncertainty and you can
access to the environment you should do
the optimistic
action such that it will give you the
optimal regress bond in the exploration
versus exploitation trade-offs
and in the setting where you don't have
access to
the environment you won't have access to
a bunch of data
which is known as the all-positive
reinforcement of battery in first
learning
uh actually many people are talking
about we should do the
aesthetic in the face of uncertainty
which means
we should optimize we should do the safe
optimization such that we are optimizing
the
worst performance among a set of uh
cloud models so in either way
we should take out the uncertainty in
our estimation
so that's motivated us to propose
some confidence interval estimation
beyond the pointless meter
uh so first idea came to us is like
okay why don't we use the bootstrap
which is very uh old but still
powerful method which is doing like this
you collected
you you already have the data set and
then you construct your
separate data set di by resample from
this data set
and then you run we call we run the
dynamic based on the data set
and we apply one estimator and after you
do the iteration you will get a bunch of
a population of uh point estimator and
based on this point at
population estimator based on this
set of finance meter you can have a
more statistic estimated from this
population like the virus
and after that you can do the upper and
lower bound confidence intervals mission
but the major problem of this
procedure is it's so computationally
expensive
solving one dice means meaning you need
to solve a mini max problem
and this is creating a lot of that
so the nature question says
is there any way to reduce the
competition
the answer is yes definitely otherwise i
will not talking
this kind of work today so
what's that actually let's consider
let's consider this bootstrap procedure
and the the variance
basically saying you want to find in the
statistic in trim case from this
set of estimation so
that is for us we can maybe do a smart
waiting such that the revision will help
me to locate
which subset will give me the worst case
and which subset will give me the best
case
so that's why we inject the minimal
and maximal in front of this set and the
minimum with respect to a
rewriting to the data set
and this repeating is a definitely you
cannot arbitrate this data set because
it will give you triple solutions say
it's located worse okay
or largest single one and put all the
mass along
on this sample so it should be you
recognize this
w in a relative uh
near neighbor of your empirical
dataset and in in terms of some
f divergence sorry about just to uh
clarify the notation on the slide what
is a curly
p superscript n minus one
oh actually that stands for uh the
simplex
so which means the w is the syntax
summation to one and
always bigger than zero and
so w is not far away from one
uniform distribution along your input
data set
i hope this gives intuition about how
this method is proposed
roughly speaking this is a smarter way
to do the
bootstrap okay
uh uh are we clear until
until now go ahead keep going
good now it seems like the optimization
terrified me at the beginning because
there's so many min max mean and the
maximum max suits that's also first but
actually the good thing is
uh we can have cloud form for the
weights
which means you don't need to optimize
it you just after you get the solution
you just calculate along this y it's
enough
and we also notice there is some
connection between the
uh covar siever and
this remaining scheme such that when you
choose special f
you will record recover the sigma
for the lower bound
uh okay
and then let's go to see some thermal
analysis
uh because this is very short talk i
don't want to talk about details but
uh we can actually propose or provide
the symptomic coverage
of this fund and also financial analysis
uh the thing i want to mention here that
is actually uh
you notice here the grate is very fast
it's no longer the one over square root
of t
here's your t which means the bond is
extremely tight
and the so far away almost to finish
everything about the corners
itself and any questions
good let's see how we can utilize this
quantize to implement
the uh of you and pfu oh if you here
stands for the optimistic
in the face of uncertainty and the pfu
stands for the
pessimistic in the face of uncertainty
uh
let's take the coordinates for oil fuel
as an example so basically every time
you use your data set
and around the corners it will provide
an upper bound
and then you can use upper bound
to do the gradient calculation for your
object function and then
you will you use this boolean to update
your policy
and then after that you have new policy
so you
you use this policy to collect the data
and so so for example this is
in the same philosophy of ucb roughly
you're speaking
it's saying you get upper bound choose
max mobile and
add your policy and track data and use
that to do
another term of evaluation and
so on and so forth and the same thing
happens to placement
perspective the only thing changes uh
you're no longer
optimize the upper bound you are trying
to optimize lower bound and
you don't have the access to the
environment so you cannot
collect the data and
if you you sharp enough you will notice
that
okay here is when you run the quantize
basically it's introducing weights to
the
to the his historic historic experience
and it's strongly related to the popular
algorithm used in practical called the
experience replay
and actually we can somehow uh
think about that uh the existing
experience replace actually doing this
in terms of either you want to do the
exploration and then you'll do the
let's go back to the rewriting scheme
that means you want to
look at the uh the larger
uh the sample with larger arrow
and we'll do the safe deployment
that means you relate to the experience
with
uh and only take the
lower only take sample with lower arrow
and yes this is some interesting
connections
and finalizing experiments about this
method and we compared to the existing
method basically the bootstrapping was
different
either the burst style the student t
and this spotlights the
confidence coverage expectation which is
issu for example in six point uh
in excesses is 0.6 and the coverage
should be 0.6 and
the blue curve is always achieve this
expectation
and the second row is the
length of the proposed length of the
composition interval compared to
different method
and the smaller the better so you can
see
our method is already beat the other
confident fascination in terms of both
the coverage and also the
weight life and
here's the conclusion uh recap what
we have done so far we propose a
series of estimators for behavioral
agnostic confidence fascination
and i only mentioned one here because
the other one is quite similar
and so this one gives
most intuitive interpretation ads you'll
do a smart
bootstrap and also this this activity
can be used for implementing the
uh two famous principles in greenhouse
learning
the future work is regrettable for the
of you with
quinas and we will release very soon and
uh
actually this is always bother us in
thai's family we don't have very good
uh so we're still working on that
and that's all thanks
and any questions thank you so much bo
indeed we'll
open up the floor for questions
[Music]
okay well i'm gonna get i'm gonna ask a
question about to get started
um if i understand correctly the
procedure
is that you have a bootstrap step uh
yeah
i don't know is there anything special
about that bootstrap any conditions on
the bootstrap process itself
no actually i just gave a brief
intuition why this method proposed this
is not our method bootstrap is always
existing that it's not our method let's
say
we think the bootstrap is so expensive
and we want to do a smart way we won't
find a smart way to do the bootstrap
which is uh goes to this
i just want to find the
maximum value in the bootstrap and the
minimum value in the bookstore
and i use this too as my upper
compression bond and the lower
competition
right so let me ask the follow-up
question then so you do find these w
vectors
and you were talking about once you
found them w star u as you were calling
it
you can then compute the upper band and
lower band
but are there any suppose
i want to use this for exploration right
um
let me see if i can understand explain
this correctly is there going to be any
uh concern about for example recomputing
a w at every step could you introduce
uh you know break some independence
assumptions along the way
if that makes sense uh russia is
then these questions go back to the
thing where they're still unsolved which
is
how you can optimize this kind of uh
problem uh nowadays it seems like one
way is saying every time i just
read because because we have the close
formula rating so every time i update
my tall and my new
i will update my weight uh update my
weights for each sample
and you don't need to do optimization
because we know the code form
but there might be there must be an
assumption on how the data is collected
right so if we now collect more data
based on this confidence interval what's
going to happen
uh you mean based on what
you mean upper bound or maybe you can
ask directly what are the conditions on
your data that allow you to provide that
upper bound okay actually the uh
our paper will say about some assumption
uh along here which is saying
the data is collected pros the data
collect procedure is like this
as zero and either from your uh
mu zero and you play your
uh connection unless as zero you you'll
get another
action and this d pi actually is a
little bit confusing it's like
you have a lot of agent it's like you
have a lot of agents
and they collect the data for you and
they just provide data for you
that's all as long as it's terrible like
sar
right so now if you wanted to use this
inside an exploration algorithm
that that assumption wouldn't hold
no actually that's the problem we are
dealing with in in
in later century so everybody is there
the problem doesn't matter
it's not related to how the data exactly
will assume it's fixed
and your question is about here which is
saying when i apply the quantize for the
uh of all of you what what it
looks like yes that's a good question i
did i didn't
have the intention to mention hyperx's
standard story is quite long
but we can chat offline it's very
tedious i can see that
i do i think there's another question
go headley home uh well i
it's not a question but maybe just a
quick comment that um
early in the day um scott mentioned that
um the safety robust reo can
be related to uncertainty or other
exploration and
what i'm going to say is that both talk
is an example of that connection
where some of the techniques from the
critical likelihood or these minimax
approaches are
actually uh some of the techniques that
the robust optimization community has
been
doing so this is an example of this
connection
and there's a question from the numbers
and yes
this is some problem uh
we do observe it so that's why i say
there is a series
of estimators and we have other as much
along this line but
i think this is the most intuitive one
so i will introduce this one
and indeed you can also do the
optimization but the trade-off is like
you pay more attention and you need to
pay more attention on the
optimizing procedure and also
the bad thing happens is when the data
gets
larger and larger you need to keep a
lower level
uh variable to be optimized so this is
very painful
so there definitely some tradeoff
between the stability and optimization
uh computer costs so
uh i think i hope this answered
questions
okay great uh so this was the queue
uh let me see what's in your
motion oh i think i misunderstood these
questions uh they are talking about the
calls from do expression
uh okay if i understand correctly none
talking about you
ignore ideal formulation and you only
apply the
gradient with respect to the
closed form after you introduce
deformation and that will introduce some
uncertain i mean unstability i think
after this
uh explicit with you and the stochastic
william uh
we do observe some instability but not
that heavy
there's some subtle difference between
the two code form things
i hope there's some such questions
all right um thank you bo uh are there
any more questions
before the monkey break
if not then thank you to all the
speakers from this morning again and uh
we will now take a coffee break
and return at 2 p.m eastern time
to start again thank you very much see
you in a bit